[Music]
this may seem very bizarre to you and
it's considered perfectly normal for the
tribe we visited now I need to warn you
that this time it wasn't one of our
comfortable happy dour missions the
reactions we received from the villagers
took us all by surprise we were welcomed
to a small village in Papua New Guinea
[Music]
with the Chiefs permission we started
sharing the message of a slab with the
entire tribe you worship and there is
nothing like after sharing the message
we asked the same question we always do
who is ready to accept this beautiful
religion of Islam and subhanAllah
instead of hundreds of people raising
their hands for the Shahada there was
pin drop silence nobody raised their
hands instead they express their
frustrations and started questioning our
points we were outnumbered in a remote
village on the other side of the world
so what did we do as Muslim we believed
in Jesus you see the name of Jesus in
the Quran you see a chapter named after
his beloved mother very a whole chapter
dedicated we continue to give down
we continued to clarify their
misconceptions we continue to answer
their questions and we told them more
about the similarities between Islam and
Christianity some of the brothers showed
them how to pray Salah step by step as
we are about to leave the village people
began surrounding our car they wanted
something from us to take their Shahada
a shadow
olara in well I said a remote tribe from
Papua New Guinea who may have never even
heard of Islam before recognized the
truth and accepted it today there is a
small group of Muslims and Papua New
Guinea tomorrow there will be thousands
in sha allah but this is how it starts
but the question is will you get a share
in this reward if you loved what you saw
I want to have a share in that reward
you can you don't have to give fifty
pounds or a hundred dollars you just
need to donate less than a cup of coffee
a day support the Dower right now click
the button on this video or visit Godot
i era org and please don't forget to
share this video because you can get the
extra reward of others donating from
your share for free to xakanaka
[Music]